ist wirklich so lecker ich liebe diesen
Burger nächster Spot Ski so Burger mein
persönlicher Favorit und warum das sehen
wir jetzt los geht's
[Musik]
und ich habe einen Bulgari Burger
bestellt und ich schwöre euch als ich
damals in Berlin war ich war ganz
alleine wie alt war über 18 oder 19 oder
so und ich bin 4 Tage lang jeden Tag zu
Burger gegangen ich meine es komplett
Ernst ich bin komplett hängen geblieben
auf dem Burger und jedes Mal schmeckt
die mir wieder genauso gut ich gehe
jetzt rein
die besten Beschreibung ist
auch diese rote Soße die so kräftig
schmeckt dann dieses Bann was quasi
während man es einfach nur hält und
zusammen schmilzt es ist unglaublich